alright fellas we got a unique
opportunity
mission too difficult
in sacrifice too great
leading your own platoon you find out
there's usually two options bad and
worse did you focus on your men because
that's what it gets you through
Pearson our sergeant never lets up busy
it was young easy it is
so scared private no sir
you should be a long way from Texas farm
boy
our cogs in the machine shows we start
going our own way the whole thing breaks
down when did you forget
they say your vet when the ramp drops
it's now or never
ever since I could hold a rifle my
brother drilled into me what it was to
be hero
I'm sorry I waited to tell you about the
baby she's pregnant oh I'm seeing
everything different now it ain't the
world that's changing it's me
you want to settle something you do it
head-on it's the only way to earn
respect
[Music]
I have to show Pearson I'm ready you
ain't got nothing to prove she's glad
you got my back
I like our odds just fine always better
in the winter sir
to the end to the end
you
[Music]
gentlemen we're on the verge of the
biggest operation of the entire war all
right fellas sir chance to break out of
Normandy easy
to focus on your men cuz that's what it
gets you through if we get this convoy
across we're in the heartland
all right funny
we thought we knew what war would be
like
nothing prepared us for this there than
you'd lose the tax there after juice
dude
[Music]
I'm not giving up on like the tune we
are cogs in the machine Joseph we start
going our own way the whole thing breaks
down when did you forget that these are
men our men
when did you forget let's take that
bridge and find our point do you think
you got some guts don't you it isn't us
it's all been leading to this
well ain't that something France
you